I exercise that you do I'm sure you you
almost have a voracious appetite I mean
I do but nothing like what I used to
mean I I fast pretty much every day I've
been doing sixteen hours what are you
doing um depends so when I'm in I split
my time between New York and California
when I'm in New York it's absolutely one
meal a day no ifs ands or buts because
it's just the schedule is such that you
know I'm seeing patients in the morning
and afternoon and I don't want to do I
don't want to waste time to eat what do
you doctrine that's a good question I
mean I trained as a surgeon and did
cancer surgery but I my practice is
based on longevity so it's sort of how
do you apply nutrition exercise sleep
stress management endocrinology lipid
ology supplements hormones all that
stuff like how do you engineer how to
make somebody live longer is my clinical
interest so yeah so in New York I eat
one meal a day so it's basically like a
22-hour fasting window and then I'm
feeding within a two hour window Wow
when I'm here
it's about this well I mean yesterday
and today it's the same like you know
today has just been kind of a busy day
you know I won't eat till dinner tonight
but my short fast would be 16 hours
where I would eat a short fit there
would be a short fence long one for me
really dude you got to get in touch with
your evolutionary so I had this
discussion with a friend this morning
because he was saying to me he can't do
16 hours well he's a [ __ ] you just told
no but I said you got to understand if
our ancestors couldn't function when
they were hungry we wouldn't be here so
it's not just that starvation a
short-term adaptation to starvation is
is necessary it's probably beneficial in
other words you know during these short
periods of deprivation of food you know
we get just a little bit more
epinephrine and norepinephrine we just
get a little bit sharper a little bit
better I I can't even I can't even
remember what it's like to eat three
meals a day it's been so long really
yeah well let me be doing this I mean
I've been doing crazy [ __ ] for ten years
nutritional wise like I'm I spent three
years in ketosis where it was you know
one day I was in ketosis for three years
lots of fasting but I think intermittent
fasting or time restricted feeding
probably at least five years and what a
for people listening what are the
benefits of that well I mean if we're
gonna be it really technical we have to
be clear that I think a lot of the
benefits are overstated and a lot of the
benefits are things that we've only
studied in animals so there's a guy
named Sachin panda at the Salk Institute
in San Diego who's I think one of the
world's experts on time restricted
feeding but you know for example a 16
hour fast in a mouse produces
unbelievable results if you take a group
of you know certain types of mice or
strains of rats or other rodents and you
in a 24-hour period deprive them of any
nutrient for 16 hours but then for 8
hours let them eat whatever the hell
they want they can't gain weight so and
and and the reason we think is that it
once you give a long enough period of
time when the animal can ramp up it's
like the enzymes in the liver that are
responsible for fat oxidation I mean
they just basically become fat burnt I
hate that term fat burning machine it's
so overused but that's babe they
basically just become unbelievably
efficient by metabolizing fat so we have
to be careful that when we extrapolate
that cuz you and I have a very different
metabolism in a mouse like a 16 hour
fast to a mouse is much longer than it
is to us so I don't know if those
benefits would extend also it's not
entirely clear the time restricted
feeding will produce the longevity
benefit that we see in other sort of
fasting or fasting mimicking types of
diets so for me what it comes down to is
I mean honestly it's just an easier way
it gives me a much more Liberty with
what I eat during my feeding window I
don't have to be nearly as restrictive
when I'm feeding if I have that period
off it's just just in terms of like my
physiologic response secondly there's a
convenience thing like I kind of hate
being tethered to eat mmm I like knowing
that if I get into a pinch like I don't
have to eat right now if I'm sitting on
the airplane and they're serving dog
[ __ ] I don't have to eat I can wait
another five hours until I eat I also
just feel much more steady in my energy
levels I
I need to vaguely remember like 10 years
ago when I was kind of like eating a
normal diet how I always had this lull
and energy after lunch like there is the
post lunch pre dinner
I just don't feel good like not that I
feel bad but like I'm not sharp I'm not
in my a-game and I don't even remember
that feels like anymore which is not to
say I feel great all the time but I
definitely don't have that vacillating
energy level
yeah I've said that to people when I
eliminated most carbs from my diet you
know and I have a friend of mine who
talked to his trainer about that his
trainers like you're crazy eat bread eat
pasta don't listen him like no don't
listen to him like just just google it
that stuff's [ __ ] terrible for you if
you want to eat carbohydrates get it
from fruits you know get it from some
natural sources but just if you have a
trainer that's telling you to eat bread
get a new [ __ ] trainer because it's
just it's not what you need it's nothing
wrong with eating if you want to
occasionally and in small doses but when
I eliminated most that stuff from my
diet I felt the exact same thing
I felt that midday nap desire go away
and they're just the fog enos about like
you at the end of the day like oh god
I'm [ __ ] tired and then I'd have to
drink a cup of coffee to get ramped back
up again and this is like never-ending
cycle of having this insulin spike and
then this crash and that is that's from
carbohydrates
it's from refined carbohydrates and you
know having too much [ __ ] sugar in
your body and everybody does it it's
like alright so this will be funny for
your so google my name and just put like
peter attea fat and you'll you're gonna
see a picture of me when I was a swimmer
cuz all this time we were talking about
me swimming you're assuming like I'm a
fit dude I was fit but fat dude fit but
a fit but totally fat and this was a
meeting Oh non-stop carbs look there
there I am see on the left there well I
wouldn't say you were fat I would say
you got you got a little paunch on ya
I don't know wait wait there's another
picture after I swim across Lake Tahoe
go to that that one right there yeah
go got there fella boozing it up yeah
but it's also you're sitting down stood
up you suck it in for a
picture on Instagram might look okay oh
no I I was definitely you know probably
what maybe 30 pounds heavier Wow butBut
bought you no body fat was much greater
and what were you eating oh I mean I
probably went three three or four
bottles of power a today because you
know raining all day and you know every
post-workout was a carb refeed and so
you're in sort of this vicious glycogen
dependent state yeah and people that
it's it's crazy that there's so many
folks out there that are living their
life that don't even understand that
this is a process they're going through
they just think this is eating and
exercise this is what happens but it's
not your body live shot up cut that off
push it away enter into a completely
different food source just change the
way you you eat your body will change
and that that just that concept the
people that sounds like horseshit it
sounds like what are you saying
you you're with you offering some
miracle cure your office no I'm saying
you will change the dimension of life
that you operate in it will change
because you won't be the same person you
won't like who you are is dependent upon
a lot of things but one of them is how
much energy you have how you feel
whether you're crashing if you change
the way you eat you change the energy
you have you change the way you feel
it'll change your behavior will change
your choices it'll change your ambitions
it'll change your potential I mean
there's so many things that will change
but